[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM CONNER: Hi,
I'm Dr. Tom Conner.
I'm the William P. Harris
Professor of Military History
at Hillsdale College.
I came to Hillsdale in 1983,
which was the same year I've
finished my PhD.
And I came here because
they offered me a job.
I've often told people
that my coming to Hillsdale
was part of an arranged
marriage but it quickly
grew into a love affair.
My doctorate in history was
in the modern European field
with an emphasis in
diplomatic history.
I've since kind of grown
that into a kind of a hobby
field in military history.
I was not trained as
a military historian,
but I was given this chair
about 10 or 12 years ago.
I've always liked history.
I grew up in a household where
my dad was a World War II
veteran and had a high
school degree only.
Like a lot of World War II vets,
I think once they got home,
he made it his ambition
to read about the war.
He and my mother would do the
chores after dinner at night,
and he'd be reading in his
easy chair for hours on end.
And that, combined with I was
very lucky in school always
to have had good teachers
and I just kind of developed
a love for history, I think
partly because my father
modeled it to me.
A liberal arts education
brings a person more fully
into contact with the whole
wide range of subjects that had
to do with our common humanity.
One of the best definitions
I've ever heard of history
is it's philosophy
teaching by example.
In the historical record,
in the study of history,
one can see just
about every dimension
of the humanity of each one
of us across the generations.
I know I'm a better
person because of the time
that I've spent here, the
students and my faculty
colleagues alike.
I mean, it's really
a community effort.
I think we try to pick each
other up, encourage each other.
Dr. Arnn likes to say
that everything we do here
is out of friendship.
And I've really not
only enjoyed that,
but I know I've been
enriched by it as well.